i would like to discuss the number one
nutrient in boosting your
collagen now it's not vitamin c even
though vitamin c definitely helps
collagen but it's something else now
what is collagen collagen is that
protein that connects everything
together out of all the protein in your
body about 35
of it is collagen so it's a connective
tissue it makes up your cartilage your
muscles your tendons your ligaments
your eyes the fascia the stuff that
holds all your muscles together it's
below your skin right on top of your
muscles it makes up your bone
even your teeth and it's all around your
skin and i think a lot of people are
trying to boost their collagen by
consuming collagen when in fact they're
missing something else and this talk is
inspired by
this book that i've been reading soil
grass in cancer the link between human
and animal health and the mineral
balance in the soil it's a fascinating
book on nutrition talking about the
relationship between the animals that we
eat and the animals that eat the grass
that comes from certain soils so if
there's some mineral missing in the soil
it's going to be missing in the plant
which the animals eat and then we eat
the animals so we're going to be
deficient as well and the number one
nutrient to boost collagen is
copper so copper has a direct effect on
making collagen preventing the loss of
collagen making elastin which is a
a protein that supports the structural
integrity of collagen and so this trace
mineral needed in a very small amount is
necessary
in the enzymes that allow proteins to
form and so the copper enzymes are all
about structural integrity so if you are
deficient in copper there are several
things that can happen with your body
tissue number one it can lead to
something called swayback or lordosis
now this happens in animals as well like
horses but it also happens in humans
where you have this excess lower back
curve and that occurs because you don't
have the structural stability to hold
everything together so things are
becoming a little bit too loose now can
also show up in your skin as loose skin
and as a side note copper has a lot of
additional benefits
including
being able to tolerate the sun longer
now what about hernias well there's some
great research i'll put the link down
below it shows the relationship between
people having hernias with a significant
deficiency in copper and that goes for
all different types of hernias whether
they're inguinal or hiatal because you
need the structural integrity
that copper gives to hold everything
together real nicely copper supports
your joints so if your joints are weak
or they're falling apart
chances are there could be a copper
deficiency and also with muscles if your
muscles are weak you may be deficient in
copper athletes that have sufficient
copper have more endurance they're more
hydrated they can go longer without
drinking water so just think about
exercise and the involvement of collagen
and connective tissue i mean you're
talking about joints muscles
everything your lower back discs need
copper to make them very very strong
your blood vessels need copper to
prevent things like varicose veins so
those are all the things that connect
copper to collagen but let's talk about
some other benefits of copper if you
have an iron deficiency anemia situation
and you don't have enough copper and you
take iron you're not going to be able to
fix your anemia copper is really
necessary with your your immune system
your white blood cells
as well as the size and shape of your
red blood cells if you're deficient in
copper you can have a disorder where
you're sweating excessively and copper
is also involved with melanin which
gives you that pigment so if you're
deficient in copper you can gray
prematurely copper also supports the
brain and it can help you keep your
balance
in the dark
or when your eyes are closed so if you
close your eyes and you feel dizzy or
disoriented that could be a copper
deficiency so let's say for example
you're going to take a shower and you
take off your shirt that momentary lack
of light can affect your equilibrium and
your balance having enough copper can
also keep your uric acid in check copper
is necessary to detoxify fluoride and by
the way the more fluoride you have in
your body the less copper you're going
to have and copper has been known to
help warm up feet and that could be
because it helps you transport iron
which is necessary in hemoglobin all
right so now what are the foods that are
high in copper liver
kidney
oysters shellfish
shiitake mushrooms and sesame seeds now
what are the common causes of a copper
deficiency well the probably the biggest
cause is that we just don't have enough
copper in our soils which then translate
to a copper deficiency in the foods that
we eat you're also going to see a copper
deficiency after gastric bypass surgery
you can also get a deficiency if you
take too much ascorbic acid okay which
is
part of the vitamin c complex normally
copper is supposed to be part of the
vitamin c complex as an enzyme
but if you're taking just a lot of
ascorbic acid out of the normal complex
that can create a deficiency of copper
too now another common cause of a copper
deficiency
is by someone taking too much zinc and
so recently a lot of people have been on
the bandwagon to take a lot of zinc and
they've probably been taking zinc out of
the
complex of a lot of trace minerals
including copper and taking too much
zinc over a period of time can throw off
your copper ratios having you be
deficient in copper so too much zinc can
lower copper too much copper can lower
zinc both zinc and copper work together
and this is why i always recommend that
you get your trace minerals in a complex
too much sugar especially fructose can
create a copper deficiency alcohol can
create a deficiency as well as consuming
too much fiber now i'm not talking about
the fiber from your foods
that come with these trace minerals i'm
talking about all these new
functional fibers that people are adding
in the so-called keto-friendly bars or
different foods now since we're on the
topic of collagen and probably a lot of
people are interested in anti-aging
i think the next video for you to watch
would be this one right here check it
out
you